that the hearing will commence of a few
formalities to do with that but once we
get onto the the hearing copper we will
start with a report on the application
from the licensing officer
we will then
um have there may be some questions for
the licensing officer if anybody needs
any clarification on the report after
that point the applicant will be asked
to present his case to the subcommittee
again once that is included there will
be an opportunity for questions to be
asked and once everyone has had
questions and that the chair is
satisfied we can proceed those persons
that have made written representations
and have requested to make all
representations to the the subcommittee
May then put their submissions and again
there may be questions for clarification
following those
um there will be there may be a summing
up from the licensing officer if there's
anything that the license officer wishes
to clarify and finally the applicant
will be able to summarize the
application the the subcommittee will
then go into a private session to
discuss the application and reach a
decision on whether to Grant the
application
so I'll now move to the first item on
the uh on the agenda and that's the
election of chair we have um councilor
Lee Parker who is the chair of the full
licensing regulatory committee so he
will be chairing this subcommittee this
morning of the future
thank you very much Nigel thank you and
good morning and welcome to this virtual
meeting of the licensing subcommittee
I'd like to remind everyone present that
this meeting will be broadcast live to
YouTube and will be capable of repeated
viewing the meeting will be recorded
except where there are confidential or
exempt items if you make a
representation to the meeting you will
be deemed by the councils who have
consented to being recorded by entering
this meeting as a speaker you are also
consenting to being recorded by the
council and to the possible use of those
sound recordings for webcasting and or
training purposes
the council members of the public and
the Press May record film photograph or
broadcast this meeting when the public
and the Press are not lawfully excluded
please note if you're joining the
meeting from a mobile phone your mobile
number may be visible on the screen and
therefore also visible on the recording
and live stream
um there are some items of etiquette
because specifically because we're we're
live streaming this event
um if we could ask please that you
ensure your microphones are muted when
you're not speaking that you do not
interrupt others uh and that if you're
attending the meeting to speak and
persistently interrupt the meeting you
may be asked to leave
additionally you'll be invited to speak
and ask questions by the chair can I ask
please that everybody waits their turn
so we'll we'll move on to item number
three which is apologies for absence
um can I ask governance officer if we
have any apologies for absence
none received share
thank you and item number four
Declaration of Interest by councilors
are there any Declarations of interest
can I ask councilor Carbondale please
thank you councilor Osborne
sorry thank you Mr chairman
um yeah I I don't know whether this is
um I am a Sudbury Town counselor so I I
better just um make that comment
thank you thank you councilor Osborne uh
so by way of introduction we'll just
have a quick nip around the room and
introduce ourselves to each other
um starting with themselves obviously
council at Lee Parker I'm uh chairing
the meeting this morning
um councilor carpondale good morning
councilor Sue carpendale
thank you and councilor Osborne
thank you Mr chairman yeah I'm Adrian
Osborne I'm a Town Council for Sudbury
and District Council for Southeast thank
you
thank you very much Council Osborne uh
and then we've got a number of offices
in the room with us this morning as well
um Mr delu you've already spoken but
could you just um introduce your uh
formal role here please
yes um the legal advisor to the
subcommittee in this application
thank you very much and then our
licensing officers please starting with
Catherine
thank you chair my name is Catherine
green licensing officer
thank you very much and Kate
thank you chair my name is Kate this all
licensing leader
excellent thank you very much and then
our governance officer please
thank you chair Governor's officer Karen
Sayer
wonderful okay and um and then I'd like
to ask please Mr Blake if you can
introduce yourselves have you got any
Representatives with you are you
representing yourself Mr Blake no I'm
representing myself I'm here with my
wife Tanya obviously applying for the
license for Gatesville excellent that's
wonderful and can I just ask you Mr
Blake as well could you just confirm uh
receipt of procedure the report itself
and copies of the relevant notice can
you just confirm you've received all of
those please
yeah I received them online and also
received a hard copy in the post
excellent that's Graham thank you very
much indeed
um right okay and at the risk of
inviting a bit of a bonfire here I do
need to ask uh others um in the room as
well to introduce
um yourselves
um so I have the following people listed
as
um uh registered to speak Mr Alex Davis
uh are you in the in the room oh yeah
that's me
wonderful thank you very much uh and uh
I have Danielle Ward
hi yes that's myself
lovely that's Grand and Jillian miles
can you
can you hear me Miss miles
okay
yeah okay let's just try one more time
there you go
um as miles are you are you looking to
speak this morning smiles
okay
we'll come back to you um Julian if
that's all right because we don't seem
to be able to um hear you for some
reason
um I note also that we've got Mr Martin
in the room uh Mr Barry Martin although
I'm aware of the fact Mr Martin that you
haven't actually sent back your
attendance hearing notice
um was it your intention to speak this
morning
only if I needed
okay so you're you're here as a as an
observer rather than a speaker Mr Martin
yes
okay and is that um I do need to ask if
I can just ask
um uh the legal officer Mr de Lu is that
um is that in order
um since Mr Martin hasn't sent back his
um hearing notice well I did yes it's
your discretion counselor if you feel
it's beneficial for the proceedings then
then
it's in your gift
okay I I mean you're you're here Mr
Martin sorry I've got no intention of um
of you know suggesting it shouldn't be
otherwise sort of thing but
um but won't be able to let you speak
I'm afraid Miss Martin all right
fair enough
okay sir thank you very much uh and Miss
miles are you um
are you able to communicate with us at
this stage
okay all right
um
we'll have to see what uh what goes on
at the moment we can't hear you um it's
your intention to speak we we can't hear
from you um at the moment so
um we'll we'll proceed as we are
okay so moving on to the next item can I
ask whether any party to the hearing
wishes to withdraw either their
application or their representation you
only need to respond to that if that is
your intention
okay I'll assume then that there's no
intention for anybody to withdraw their
application
um question to the licensing officer
have there been any requests from any of
the parties for permission to call
witnesses
excellent and have the parties indicated
they wish to present documentary or
other material
no chat
excellent
um okay so back to you Mr Blake could I
ask you please to estimate the time
required to present your case and to ask
questions of other parties uh to the
hearing
yeah
sorry was you speaking to me chair
uh yes indeed so yeah so we just just
five or ten minutes will be absolutely
fine excellent okay thank you very much
indeed and I'll ask the same question to
anybody else that would like to speak as
well
um does anybody plan on an elongated
um presentation at all
not myself
superb thank you very much indeed
right okay in which case with the
formalities done uh I will proceed to
the substantive item which is item
number five uh and I'm going to ask the
licensing officer Catherine green to
present the report B stroke l a sub
slope stroke 22 stroke three and to
summarize the matter under consideration
so uh when you're ready please Catherine
thank you chair
this hearing is to determine an
application made for the grant of a new
premises license made under Section 17
of the licensing act 2003 by Mark Blake
in relation to the premises Courtyard
tap 26 to 27 gains for Street Sudbury
Suffolk co10 2eu
the application was received by the
licensing Authority on the 12th of March
2023 and a copy of this is attached to
this report as appendix a the
application made has been subject to the
statutory consultation period as
prescribed by regulation the notice is
advertising the application have been on
display at the premises and published in
the Suffolk food press on the 23rd of
March 2023 Edition
for details of the proposed activities
and timings are contained in the
application form attached as appendix a
to this report
hearing is necessary to determine the
application following receipt of
representation representations sorry
which have not been withdrawn the
subcommittee will be aware that its
consideration is confined to promotion
of the four licensing objectives and the
need or commercial demand for license
premises are not considerations for the
licensing Authority when discharging its
licensing functions
this
is outlined by Secretary of State at
paragraph 1419 of the guidance issued
under Section 182 of the licensing act
2003 in carrying out its licensing
functions the licensing Authority must
have regard to its statement of
Licensing policy published under Section
5 of the act and any guidance issued by
the Secretary of State under Section 182
where revisions are made to the
legislation or guidance issued by the
Secretary of State there may be a period
of time when the local statement of
Licensing policy is inconsistent with
these revisions in these circumstances
the licensing Authority will have regard
and give appropriate weight to the
relevant changes guidance and its own
statement of Licensing policy
the licensing Authority has received no
representations from responsible
authorities under the licensing act 2003
there has been nine representations
received made by other persons which
includes local residents businesses and
residence associations and this is
attached as appendix D to this report
the subcommittee must having regard to
the representations made take such of
the steps if any as it considers
appropriate for the promotion of the
licensing objectives
to Grant the license subject to
condition
distant view operating schedule
accompanying the application
modified to such extent as the authority
considers appropriate that the promotion
of the licensing objectives and subject
to any mandatory conditions which must
be included in the license
to exclude and the scope of the license
any of the licensable activities to
which the application relates to refuse
to specify a person in the license as a
privacy supervisor or to reject the
application
these purposes conditions of the license
are modified if any of them are altered
or omitted or any new condition is added
any party agreed by the decision taken
by the licensing authority irrespect of
this application as a statutory right of
appeal to the magistrates Court this
concludes my summary check
super job thank you very much indeed
Catherine okay so I'm obliged at this
point to ask if any parties not yet the
subcommittee minded but if any parties
to the hearing have any questions for
the licensing officer so that's that's
questions rather than points or
statements because everybody will have
their opportunity to make those shortly
but has anybody got any questions on
anything that the licensing officer is
just um stated
excellent that's Grand I'll take the um
that is as a no then uh and the same
question of members uh if I can ask do
the subcommittee members have any
questions at this stage of the licensing
officer
no thank you Jim
that's what I was born
okay uh at which point then I'm going to
ask the applicant Mr Blake um to present
your case sir if you will uh the
applicant that's you may call witnesses
have given permission by the
subcommittee but uh um since there are
no president I presume um we won't be
doing that so I'll just ask you uh to
present your case in your own time
please Mr Mike
thank you very much chair uh we've gone
through the introductions uh after
reading uh all the documents that were
sent to myself I've tried to answer as
many questions as I can as quick as I
can uh
it wasn't mentioned the hours I actually
already have a tap room which is in
Halstead now I'm trying to duplicate in
uh Sudbury the hours trade in at the
moment in my house and also if are
successful in the application would be
Monday to Thursday 12
until 8 pm on a Friday I would like to
stay open till maybe nine but I just
want to make it clear this meeting is a
tap room it's not a bar it's a tap room
which will be
showcasing my beers that I produced in
gosfield at the brewery uh the people
that use the tap room at the moment
which I will feel will be very similar
in Sudbury I'm more senior people it's
The Tap Room isn't full of kids running
around it's not full of people drinking
as much lager as possible it's a tap
room to Showcase my beers which which
are Ales
uh one of the one of the objections or
representation was a flat upstairs which
I do understand that's also the case in
Halstead there's a flat upstairs I've
been there for three years I've never
had one complaint as yet and I don't
Envision is having any complaints in
Sudbury uh CCTV will be put as soon as
if we were successful will be introduced
to Gainsborough Street which is
obviously a good thing a good deterrent
uh music was mentioned which again I
understand I wouldn't want to live
upstairs in the park that's been in
music the music will be played from an
iPad and it is background music it's
very very uh quiet just background music
uh delivery of goods was mentioned as a
representation there will be no delivery
of goods ahead because all the
deliveries will come to my Brewery which
is based in gosfield which again that
happens in Halsted at the moment there's
a very very small path outside in-house
it's very similar to Sudbury but there
will be no trucks no delivery wagons
anything will be delivered to gosfield
also the price of a beer my my my
beer is quite expensive compared to
other places in Sudbury which I've
looked at you can go to quite a few
establishments and buy a pint of beer
for under two pounds if your intention
was to drink beer as quick as possible
uh my lowest price would be four pounds
which in-house did that prices out
people that want cheap beer as quick as
possible that it just does not happen
um
so I'm just going through my notes
yeah so so that really sums up the hours
the type of people that use the Tap Room
uh hopefully I've answered the music and
the delivery and the price of beer
obviously any questions I'll try and
answer as quick as I can but thank you
very much
excellent no thank you Mr Blake for
being so uh so succinct and I'm I'm
quite certain that there will be
um you know lots of questions for you
um so again I'm obliged at this point to
go around the table uh and to ask
everybody in turn if they have any
questions now for the sake of order we
need to do this in a specific order
um and these are just questions uh for
Mr Blake uh again everybody will have an
opportunity to make their own statement
surely so this is just questions
um of Mr Blake um if we can and I'm
going to start with um
um you know the other persons
um in the room the other persons if we
can start in an order we've got
um Mr Davis do you have any questions
for Mr Blake
all right yeah I
I
um
I'm just hearing what you
want using deliveries and they're being
deliveries to glossfield instead how
then does the ale get to the premises in
your mind
okay that will be transported by myself
what I was trying to mention about the
deliveries as you know being in Sudbury
it's a very tight area for lorries and
there's nowhere to go so basically I
will probably have maybe one or two
barrels of beer which can fit in my
boots I will then Park up where
obviously it's legally depart and roll
the barrels over I will store some
barrels on site in a air-conditioned uh
area which means if I'll run out of beer
I've got some there there's room there
to have a store
so this is where I was trying to probe
exactly is where exactly would it be
legal to park and roll the barrel
presumably down the street I can't think
of anywhere
nearby that you would be able to do that
okay well you know I don't really know
Sudbury as well as you guys do obviously
there was opposite the tech room there
was a lay-by there where we parked when
we viewed the premises of it you could
park there for short space of time
but again the deliveries can be at any
time it can be early in the morning or
late at night it's because I'm doing it
myself I'm not reliant on someone else
to deliver
okay
um
I will leave that point as it stands
um I think the other question I would
have is
you've said a lot of things which are
very reasonable about actually wanting
something that's quite uh moderate in
comparison to your application right uh
the hours are significantly reduced uh
you're talking about iPad music being a
lot quieter you need a question uh Mr
Davis please I guess would you be
amenable to certain restrictions or
reductions in the scope of your
application in order to pull it through
or is it as it stands and only as it
stands
now I can answer that easily uh
the situation at
I don't want to keep referring to
Halstead but that's something I did
three years ago so it makes sense it's
very similar size building very similar
demographics
I'm licensed there by Braintree
from 12 midday to 11 7 days a week it is
never open past eight o'clock Monday to
Thursday and weekends it shut at nine
what that does is stop anyone coming in
who wants to drink as much as possible
it's not that type of place if you've
been to a Tap Room you'll probably
understand most people go in there are
couples it's not in there to drink as
much lager as possible it just doesn't
happen by shutting the eight
and having CCTV I've not had a police
called once in three years and I've also
not had one complaint from a flatter
pass so that's just if you Google the
courtyards happening house it you'll see
the premises and by chatting early it's
not most people don't go out until after
eight o'clock at night that doesn't
attract those type of people and I'm
happy for concessions we put in place
thank you Mr Blake
right I'll deal thanks
okay thank you very much Mr Davis
um Danielle Ward do you have any
questions to ask of Mr Blake
um I'd like to know what Mr Blake's plan
is for management of the courtyard being
that his Courtyard is obviously next to
mine and his upstairs seating area
overlooks my garden
thank you very much Mr Blake
I'm finding hard to understand that the
management of the I don't understand the
questions sorry
um
Danielle could I can reword it yeah yeah
if if you can concisely please
so obviously Miss Baker said that he
plans on pricing out a lot of certain
clientele but he's not going to know
who's going to comment until it's open
and you know what are his guarantees for
watching over what people are doing in
his Courtyard
is that player Mr Blake yeah that's 100
yeah obviously you know I have a duty of
care I'm working there it's a family-run
business and my son will be running it
or I'll be working there or my wife will
be working there
we we we we see exactly what goes on all
the time in Houston and we will I can't
guarantee what happens outside of the
premises but I will be as Vigilant as I
can be that's all I can tell you
okay Miss Blake any other questions at
this time
sword
uh no
okay and obviously you'll have an
opportunity to make a representation
shortly yourself so um thank you very
much now
um uh Ms Mars I know we were struggling
earlier I'm conscious and Keen that if
you do want to speak that that you can
do so
um so uh hopefully um you're able to
join in but do you have any questions
for Mr Blake please
okay so we're not able to perhaps yeah
um
if Miss miles is able to access the chat
function on here if she could
perhaps type in the question you could
read it out yeah sure sure if that's an
option on me Miss miles might be here
saying that she you know doesn't want to
speak and that's absolutely fine as well
but if you're able to uh uh as most
perhaps you can use the chat function to
type your question in
okay
right okay well if if there is anything
that appears in the um in the chat box
shortly we'll we'll revert back to it
but we've got an opportunity at this
stage now that everybody's had an
opportunity to at least ask a question
we can come back to Julie Mars if we
need to so could I ask
um subcommittee members
um uh for their questions at this point
um councilor carlfdale starting with you
do you have any um any questions for Mr
miles at this point thank you uh good
morning Mr Blake
um
thank thank you for the details that
you've just supplied that was very
helpful
um I do have some practical questions
um
we're quite interested to see how you
intend to access the garden uh given
that it appears to be through the toilet
and only one WC for the premises can can
you clarify how how you propose to to do
that
yes the first thing should I be
successful there will be uh another
Laboratory
put in place uh it won't just be the
ones or they're a unisex toilet as for
the garden I can't see that being used
to start with because it's a very very
small space it's very overgrown and
there is obviously a flat above it so
until I can't really answer your
question until I go down there and see
exactly what the setup is but I'm not
going to be using that to start with no
okay thanks
um I was interested to hear you you have
a brewery are you actually a brewer
yes I have I have a brewery in gosfield
which we set up in 2018
where people can come and buy bottles
but they can't drink the beer on site
which is why I set up house that which
is now I thought Subway would be a great
area to have there it's actually an
award-winning Brewery we are we have
rewards on camera as well which come to
a brewery and attack room so that's the
type of people that will come and drink
beer uh I keep going on but I do I do
I'm sure you've all been to tap rooms it
will be shut at eight o'clock people
come to enjoy the beer one or two pints
not to drink dozens it's not that type
of place
uh craft beers yes
um you were talking about barrels
earlier on presumably also bottled beer
and and things of that nature
yes the barrels would be they they are
nine gallon barrels which is 72 pints
they will be on the stand which will be
shown to the public
they will be a fridge with bottle beers
and we also will sell our own everything
from a brew everything that's done is
from the brewery so I don't send
anything out of gosfield all my beer
will be bottled here labeled here capped
here and then they'll put on the in
presentation if people want to take
bottles away but all the beers I do ate
beers so you probably have three or four
on display that are rotated the people's
choices yeah yeah the darker beers don't
sell so well in the summer so but yeah
they'll that they'll be on display yeah
okay thank you
um I wonder if you can help me with the
um the layout diagrams that we've got I
was a little bit confused uh I'm looking
firstly at the layout for the ground
floor
um and you've put some dimensions in
um we seem to have lost a couple of feet
on one side was that just a a sort of
typographical error
um on on one side on the right as I look
at it you've got eight foot ten which is
matched on the left and on the right
side again you've got 16 feet six and on
the left you've got 14 foot five inches
is that just a measuring error
oh we didn't measure it the
um measurements are already there so I
just copied what was on all right
is it actually the same across the bar
area well it's a bit wonky so I'll just
presume because it's an old building it
was wonky and the difference was just
perfect yes
I mean that's something we can certainly
uh you know I know
we can barely come back to you and
answer that question okay
um what what prompted me asking that was
that I was trying to work out the
relationship of the upstairs seating
area to the ground floor there's some
sort of stairs put in and from your
drawings
um given there's a window as well it
looks as if your upstairs seating area
is in fact over the main bar area would
that be correct
yes yes it would be yes yes
uh because I obviously we have a
representation we've talked about the um
the flat upstairs but I can't see where
that upstairs flat would be if it's uh I
think it was a mention in one of the
representations that it would be over
the someone's bedroom would be over the
main bar area but it looks as if the
upstairs seating area that you're
talking about would be over the main bar
area is that correct yes that is correct
yes right okay
um right so that appears to clarify that
I think flat
slightly over the left hand side of the
building which is where the toilet area
will be and it's just a very small room
so it won't be directly over the bar at
all yes so obviously you would have sort
of different issues to deal with not
licensing ones but but looking at how
you might need to change things within
the building which are not not our Our
concern
um what might be of interest to us is is
how you might have some sound deadening
and I know you're talking about a
different type of of Pub
um from from what we would normally
expect but um are you are you proposing
any sound deadening to try to mitigate
any impact on on nearby residents
I I wasn't because
as I said it is background music
um voices you know okay I mean it's it
you know I'll look at most things that
you guys recommend of course I will I
want to try and gain this license and if
you guys have right you need to do XYZ
if it's commercially viable I will
certainly look at it there's you know
anything out there that can help then of
course I will I will look at it and if
that needs to be done
uh
but with a music it certainly wouldn't
need to be done because it's it's very
background the noise of people is a
tricky one
uh
again it doesn't get that noisy in-house
dead so I've not had one complaint for
noise
uh nor the person and that is the person
is actually upstairs um
they live upstairs and they are
absolutely in fact they come in there
again so but I'll I'll have to look at
it if someone says look that noise is is
awful then then of course I'll go look
at it yes yeah it's an old building
isn't it a great two-listed building
yes okay
um I think that's me for the moment
chair thank you well it is it is at
least a building yeah sorry I'll keep
muting I'm muting so
okay it's absolutely fine and um thank
you as ever councilor Carver value
you've asked all of my questions and and
some in advance so um that that should
save some time now just before I move on
to councilor Osborne
um there is a question from Ms Mars in
that well there's there's a statement in
the uh in the chat from Ms miles
um it's not for me to um uh to to put
the question
um or to it to uh you know to anticipate
what the question is but the statement
says I'm concerned that if you have a
license for longer opening hours that
once you are established you will extend
your opening hours so
um if if I were asking a question
following on from that my question would
be is it your intention to extend your
opening hours
definitely not as I said attack women
Halstead has been there three years it
shuts at eight o'clock nine o'clock on
Friday nine o'clock on Saturday and
actually it shuts at six on a Sunday
it's all avoidance of people that may
want to come in here and spoil what's
will be a pleasant experience for lots
of people uh I don't want that spoiled
by people
I have to be very careful how I talk
here I'm not used to doing this guys so
I do apologize if I'm thinking ahead the
people that come in I don't want their
experience to be ruined by people
just for example just quickly I'll tell
you a story I had a guy come up
yesterday last week and said I don't
come in your place in Halstead I said
why he said because I drink lager I said
well I can do your bottle of he said
well I'm getting so much cheaper at the
end of the road so I said okay well I
hope you enjoy at the end of Road that's
not the sort of person I want in Techron
okay okay all right so to answer the
question you will definitely not seek to
extend your hours is the answer Mr Blake
thank you
um okay I have got um another question
as well but I'm just going to see if
counselor Osborne um do you have any
questions for Mr Blake at this point
actually I'm looking at Council Osborne
uh I'm not entirely sure if you're still
with us or not counselors oh there you
are no no I've been listening intently
Mr chairman
and I can just um
morning Mr Blake Antonia
um
yeah everything everything that you have
stated about um
uh the opening hours
Etc I'm still a little bit confused
because you put to 11 o'clock
I don't
does that mean you're having to change
your license in-house I mean I just
clarified I might have missed something
that you said when you were offering um
councilor Carbondale uh
um answers so
is that is that now a changeable uh
venue now in terms of hours
yeah I mean I can I'm I'm obviously I'm
not used to these sort of things but
going back on house dirt I thought the
license in 12 to 11 but I just wanted to
explain to you guys that it still shuts
that he's got and I'm happy to make an
amendment if that's if that's the case I
do not wish to open later than eight
o'clock nine o'clock on a Friday
Saturday and six o'clock on Sunday
yeah thank you for that like I mean that
just needs to be um put in in writing
really because I can probably just
clarify councilor Osborne just to
confirm that your application is amended
to the hours of 12 P.M to 8pm
Sunday to Thursday and 12 P.M to 9 p.m
Fridays and Saturdays
can you confirm that's
what you want to do yeah that's
absolutely fine yes thank you and it
won't change definitely not because
otherwise it just it just takes away
what I set out for it to be in the first
place but there's always the opportunity
to vary your life's license in the
future but for today's purposes we're
considering granting a license on that
basis thank you yeah thank you Nigel
thank you Mr Blake just one other um you
you talked about where you're going to
have to deliver your your stores from uh
from my memory
um although there's a car park just or
was it what was called the Hardwick
house surgery the lay-by I I can't think
of one that is opposite your opposite of
the old bizarre building
but there is one just further down as
you're going towards the fire station on
the right hand side which there's a
lay-by there which I think is
near the restaurant which is open near
new restaurant which is open there
so that it to for you is that is that
the area that you're talking about
delivering from it and two yeah there
was a yeah I think that yeah towards a
fire station I think there was a Chinese
and a lay-by there which which sometimes
people Park and sometimes you can't but
as I say the delivery will take minutes
right okay and just a clarification
again
um the redlined areas that you've got in
in the uh in in that area the bar area
that's just for uh consumption of beer
so you're not actually looking at
anybody coming out of that area with
with drinks or um an off sales license
which you state you you were going to
apply will you have to apply for an off
sales license then for people to take
bottles out yeah that's something I may
apply for but you are right within that
red area is for the consumption yes
okay well that's very kind thanks uh
thanks for your answers uh Mr Blake
thank you
thank you councilor Osborne um right
jolly good so I I
Mr Blake just for context and forgive me
you might have already mentioned this
but just for context can you just give
me an idea what what is your length of
experience in in the trade so
okay I've been brewing since I was you
know very very young uh not very
successfully the beer was awful then
when I moved to gosfield about 10 years
ago I bought a house that had a coach
house uh adjacent to it and we started
to brew there with something called a
grain father in which we brewed
successful beer and it was three years
ago that we started a brewery which has
been working very well
sorry five years and as I said earlier
in fact we've won awards from camera
which come regularly to the brewery and
the tech room so it's been probably 10
years or so
okay any premises in
um Halsted has been running you saved
for what five five years then yeah
three years since no yes since 2020 the
brewery was 2018.
and house that was 2020 yes excellent
okay sir thank you very much indeed okay
I don't have any um further questions at
this stage
um for you
um so I'm just going to quickly revert
back to my counselor colleagues just to
see if there are any further questions
from uh from either counselor at this
stage
no I haven't Mr chairman and uh
um Council I'll ask most of the
questions that I'd already uh looked
down to ask yeah indeed right thank you
sue okay so in that case then um could I
ask finally if our uh licensing officers
have any questions of Mr Blake at this
time
no Jeff
no chair thank you brilliant okay thank
you very much indeed okay in which case
then we will uh we will move on and I'm
now going to ask uh each of the other
persons to present their cases
um if they so wish to do so
um so again uh doing so in order I'm
going to ask uh Mr Davis Alex Davis to
do so and then at the end of your
presentation Miss Davis I'm going to say
if anybody has any questions for you so
uh when you're ready sir over to you
hi there yeah
uh thank you very much Mr chair
um so essentially the reason that I put
in a request to be able to speak was to
be able to respond uh fundamentally I've
said what I've said in my documents
I do have concerns about the uh the
application having been put in with
limited site of the venue and the
parking surrounding you know when we're
talking about deliveries being taken
pretty much that lay by by Kohinoor is
right next to my house very much so I
know it very well
that is an area where I'm not sure
you're going to be able to Park the
school streets uh car park is constantly
full and then adjacent you have a care
home and a fire station
all of which you need emergency access
to and all of which you're in one ways
and very narrow roads
um you have a lot of car accidents take
place on the corner because it's a
four-way Junction and
I don't mean any disrespect to Mr Blake
by this but simply he's senior venue
liked it and put in an application and
not necessarily had the opportunity to
scope out some things in the same way as
we're seeing with other aspects of the
application
I kind of Stand By The representations
that I've made but mostly I'm here to
address any kind of qualms you may have
with it
um otherwise I'm happy to heal
wonderful thank you very much indeed Mr
Davis for explaining your situation I
think that's perfectly fair and
reasonable as well
um so uh so in the same format I'm
obliged to ask if uh if people have any
questions of you Mr Davis and that's
starting with yourself Mr Blake now
those are questions not statements um
and I'm I must insist on that so do you
have any questions for Mr Davis no no I
understand exactly what he says so yeah
thank you for that
excellent that's wonderful uh and again
um do any of the other parties uh either
Miss Ward or Miss Mars have any
questions uh for Mr Davis at this point
okay I'll assume from the silence that
that's uh that's a no uh and so I'll ask
again members
um councilor carpendale do you have any
questions for Mr Davis at this point
no thank you chair
super job and also councilor Osborne do
you have any questions no thank you uh
Mr chairman no I'm I'm quite satisfied
with uh Mr Davis's response is thank you
okay that's Grand and then finally uh to
our licensing officers do you do you
have any questions for Mr Davis
no thank you chair
and no thank you chair
okay all right thank you very much for
your time Mr Davis thank you
um so we will then move on to Danielle
Ward
um Miss Ward again
um you know that you know the drill by
now if um if you've got uh any points
you'd like to make now is the time to do
it and we'll ask questions
um at the end if you if you'd like to
speak
thank you
um so first I'd like to clarify that my
bedroom is actually over the downstairs
seating area and the toilet area
there are also
mine is actually right over one of those
um it seems like Mr Blake actually
hasn't been aware of that when he's been
looking at the property it has found it
slightly annoying today that he keeps
saying he's had no complaints from the
current person living above his premises
in Houston because different people are
different I've lived in a pub before I
appreciate he says it's not going to be
a pub it's going to be a tap room but I
have lived in one before caused a lot of
trauma and I actually bought my house to
move away from another princess like
that as well I would never have bought
my home had this been a pub beforehand
and I am now you know living there I'm
too late in the process to consider
buying somewhere else to consider buying
somewhere different
I appreciate that he has said today that
you know he would like a certain type of
clientele but you cannot make any
guarantees until the premises are open
and he has admitted himself sorry
admitted today that he has no control of
people once they are outside the
premises so there are no guarantees that
it will not cause public nuisance or
issues for Public Safety
um
one of my main questions really would be
is Mr Blake willing to open this Tap
Room on the ground floor of his own home
because that is what he is
suggesting to do to my home I waited
more than 10 years to be in a position
to buy my home and this is my first time
as a young girlish person
and it took me a long time to be able to
do this myself and
it's been a very difficult process to
buy the house and right at the end stage
Mr Blake has made this application
um I appreciate that obviously
Public Safety and
those similar matters have to be the
Forefront of your mind but I would urge
all of you to consider whether you'd be
willing to Grant this application if it
was your home that was next to you and
above a tap room or a public house
whichever you'd like to call it and and
just take those into consideration for
me today thank you
thank you very much Miss Ward thank you
and um yeah your your concerns are noted
it's um it's clearly evident that you
you have those concerns so take that on
board
um uh Mr Blake
um do you have any questions and it must
be a question rather than a statement
please do you have any questions for uh
Ms Ms Ward
no none at all
thank you very much
um and again I'll come back to um
councilor uh well actually I'll ask if
anybody else Mr Davis
um or Miss Mars do you have any
questions
um at this time for Ms Ward
could I just ask one question which is
uh can we confirm whether your property
is also grade two listed and therefore
you would have significant difficulty
with
installing soundproofing within your own
home
yes Warehouse is also greatly listed
great thanks
thank you very much Mr Davis
um
any other questions from any of the
other parties at the moment I can't see
anything in the chat at this stage but
we can come back to that if um if needs
to be in which case I'll um I'll move on
councilor Carpenter do you have any
questions for
um Ms Ward
um thank you chair uh yes morning Ms
Ward
um we we seem to have some difficulty
over the location of of the the upstairs
seating area for for what is proposed
and and what you're saying is your
bedroom
um that they seem to be in conflict
is there any way you can help us with
with identifying the exact situation of
the of the rooms
um
so if the premise is 25 to uh sorry 26
to 27 is is on the corner you have a
front door that is closest to the corner
which is I believe proposed to be the
actual bar area
and then you go through a doorway to the
left that is I believe proposed to be
um a downstairs seating area and the
toilet through to the garden
the that seating area downstairs has
like a non-functional doorway
and then as you go over to the left is
my front door which leads directly into
my living room so my living room is sort
of next to downstairs seating area and
then as you go up by stairs my bedroom
is to the right so my bedroom window is
immediately in line with a
non-functional door downstairs and then
as you carried on over to the right he's
got the upstairs seating
I'm sorry if that's confusing
uh no thank you it sounds as if the
upstairs seating area would be
immediately adjacent uh to your to your
bedroom
yes it would okay thank you very much
that that clarifies it thank you thank
you chair thank you
thank you very much councilor Osborne do
you have any questions
thank you Mr chairman no I I the very
questions that uh I was gonna
talk uh ask was exactly what Sue has
just mentioned it it's it's a bit
confusing in the upstairs area so I I
tend to agree with with with the council
thank you
okay thank you very much um Miss Ward if
if I may um if I could ask a question
just for clarity could I ask
um how long you have owned the premises
how long you've been in the premises I
know you've written in your report but I
think what I'd like Clarity on is
obviously that premises historically has
been a retail uh unit
um and so if it weren't a tap that we're
being or a Tap bar that were being
proposed here it might well be another
commercial operation so would your
objection hold if it were any other
commercial operation or or is it is it
this application specifically and it
might be a bit unfair because it's only
this application that we're dealing with
but again I'm just looking for context
um just just to see how your feelings
are so how long have you been there was
it a retail operation when you moved in
uh and um and what's your views to it
being a commercial operation of some
sort in the future
and so I have owned the property for
exactly a month today and I've lived
there for three weeks but I have been in
the process of buying it for the last
eight months
um I obviously knew it was a commercial
property when I bought the house and I
did say that in my representation
however bizarre's hours were much
reduced it was a member team members of
staff at any one time yes my objection
is specifically to this application if
it was another shop or if it was an
office arrow for example their hours of
operation are likely to be my hours of
operation and my job and they would be
closed when I come home
okay thank you very much it's very clear
thank you
um okay so that's all the questions that
I have
um assuming that there's no other
questions from counselors
um I'll again I'll move to the licensing
officer and ask if the licensing officer
has any questions of Miss Ward please
yeah
no questions thank you chair
excellent okay uh now I'm just going to
enter into the chat because I can see
that there is
um okay so there's a photograph that's
been entered into the chat that's
understood and I think that's from Mr
Davis thank you Mr Davis
um I think we understand where the um
where the premise is uh or where you're
I see where you are relevant to um to
the premises involved okay that's fine
right okay so the next bit um I might
need some guidance here from officers
because uh Ms miles has indicated that
she would like to speak but obviously we
uh we're we're struggling to make
contact with Miss miles so um
I don't know if our officers have any uh
any guidance on how we might um and how
we might conduct that because
unconscious of people have asked to
speak they should be able to
yes chair it's difficult
um obviously we're time constrained in
dealing with this application
um and today was unfortunately we had to
do it remotely because of other
circumstances
um there is the opportunity to
put things into the chat which
you've indicated you would accept
in this respect we do have the written
representation
um all representations are only there to
um just to amplify what has already been
put down in lighting so you have had the
the representations
um and so you are aware of what those
representations are it is unfortunate
for this unless
um
you know circumstances to change the
last few minutes I think you will need
to proceed um if you want to give a few
more minutes
to allow
um some more information through the
chat function
um that's your discretion uh it feels
that there should be something that you
need to add but like I say you've had
the written representation so
fundamentally you are aware of what the
objections are from that person okay
thank you very much for for the guidance
then in that case Mr delu what I would
ask then perhaps Miss miles if you could
just indicate if you can just quickly
indicate in the chat whether you wish to
make any further points or or whether
you're happy to proceed are you are you
able to do that for us
we'll just allow a few moments for
the smiles to type in the chat
if not I'll assume that we could just uh
move on
okay yeah that's understood so miss
miles is in the chat said that she'd
like to make some further points
um so we'll wait for those to come
through
okay uh so miss miles has made a point
in the in the chat I'm sure we can all
say it but I will read it out
um uh and I think um there's some
emphasis here that it has not been
mentioned that this is a conservation
area uh as well as an area of many
listed buildings uh enough has not been
made of the safety issues with people
coming out into the very narrow Pavement
in front of the building where cars
frequently pass at excessive speed so
that that's that's the point that's been
made now I'm I'm conscious that we're
we're not going to we're just not going
to be able to ask questions
um uh of Miss Miles because
um you know there won't be an
opportunity to to be able to respond in
a reasonable period of time
um so I I think I can just make an
assurance uh to miss Mars that though
those will be cases I'm sure that will
be taken into account
um uh when counselors retire to make
their deliberations
um so your point there has been noted I
think and we'll we'll give that to you
consideration I think that's probably
the fairest thing that I can say about
that
at this stage
um so in the absence if they're not
being any further points that are coming
forward
um councilor Carbondale
thank you chair just um in response to
Ms miles comment there I wonder if we
say to the to Mr Blake is there a
planning application involved with with
this proposed business
um and if so would the traffic issues be
dealt with more by by planning I know
that's sort of two-stage question but um
yes clearly there's a concern about
there and I wonder if that's
um a question for Mr Blake with due
respect to whether it might be a
question if it's a planning question
for our legal officer to address
actually but it's a perfectly valid
question but I wonder if it's something
that our legal officer could address the
second Point certainly thank you chair I
mean obviously this would fall under the
licensing objective of the protection of
Public Safety
um generally speaking when we're dealing
with licensing applications the public
safety aspect is in relation to the
operation of the premises
um
of the premises itself whether it is
safe for customers whether it is safe to
accommodate a certain number of
customers whether the
um
the activities taking place within the
premises are done in in a safe way and
not putting people to risk
obviously there is an impact on the
commercial premises where it is next to
a highway but that's not uncommon but
you have to give a limited weight in
respect of safety issues away from the
premises such as Highway issues and I'm
back to what councilor carpenter has
asked about the the planning permission
if there is a planning application and a
planning permission then the highways
Authority will be a statutory consultee
in respect of that matter and as experts
in Highway matters they will be the ones
that may raise issues relating to
highway safety that's their concern
and planning applications do War more
with the um the the effects and the
impact on the amenity of the area and
wider issues
um so you're really concentrating on um
in this respect when you think about
Public Safety you're looking at the
direct impact that the property is
having on
um maintenance customers it can knock on
to to the general public but I would say
that I'd have to be a fairly exceptional
circumstance for you to consider you'd
have to be fairly certain that that the
circumstances are are unusually enough
to have an impact
um so hopefully that verifies that for
you yes thank you and I I hopefully that
might also assist Miss miles
um with her concerns thank you for that
thank you very much Council arpendale
um okay and so finally I'm just going to
ask
um our officers whether they finally
have any um any questions or anything as
a result of
um uh Miss miles this point at all
thank you chair
wonderful okay thank you very much uh Mr
Davis your comment in the uh in the chat
box has been noted as well thank you
very much
um okay so I'm going to uh you know so
we we've been able to ask questions both
of the applicant and indeed of the uh
the other representatives in the room um
so I'm satisfied with all the questions
uh have been asked
um could I therefore ask please for the
licensing officer
um if if you wish to give a closing
statements or to summarize any points
which need Clarity at this point please
I've got nothing better to add you thank
you great
uh
in which case I will ask the applicant
um Mr Blake do you have anything finally
that you would like to uh that you'd
like to say
now uh obviously thank you for your time
uh and thank you
for your questions uh we'll we'll go
from there but uh yeah I appreciate your
time thank you
you're more than welcome that's great
okay so for the benefit of everybody in
the room now
um what will happen next is that the
um the subcommittee members will retire
uh and we will we will make our
deliberations so
um what I need to do is to make a motion
at this point
um which I'll do so now on the basis
that the subcommittee considers that the
public interest in excluding the public
outweighs the public interest in its
deliberation being held in public it has
resolved that under section 100 a four
of the Local Government Act 1972 the
public be excluded from the meeting on
the grounds that it involves the likely
disclosure of exempt information as
defined in part one of schedule 12 of
the acts on the ground set out in
regulation 14 two of the licensing act
2003 hearings regulation 2005 and I will
require a seconder to that motion please
thank you very much and you're in
agreement councilor Osborne thank you
thank you Miss Jamie yes I am indeed
excellent okay so uh uh so the members
of the subcommittee will now leave this
meeting the live stream will be stopped
um everybody is perfectly at Liberty to
remain on this thread while uh model
subcommittee members make their
deliberations and we'll uh we'll come
back to everybody as quickly as we can
so
okay ready
wonderful okay in which case uh I'm
going to ask our legal officer Mr delu
to return and to
um give the decision announce the
decision of the subcommittee if you'll
be prepared to do that now please Mr
talou
thank you chair and thank you for for
waiting the subcommittee of um consider
this
um great detail
um
just to start with like to say that
licensing applications
um always come with a presumption that
the the application will be granted as
applied for unless their representations
made
um in respect to that application and
those representations satisfy the the
licensing Authority but there is an
unacceptable impact on any of the the
licensing objectives
um consider the the highway and delivery
issues
um and as mentioned during the the
Committee hearing
um there is limited weight
um the subcommittee can can give them
those matters
um and they can the uh subcommittee
thought there was insufficient evidence
to show that those matters would lead to
an unacceptable impact on the licensing
objectives
the main concern in this matter is the
adjoining property
but the difficulty that the the
subcommittee have in this is that this
is a new Venture but there is no
evidence to show any historical problems
with with noise so the
subcommittee are having to try and
anticipate the issues
they've been helped greatly by the
applicant
reducing the hours
to 8pm from Sundays to Thursdays and to
9 pm on
Fridays and Saturdays
they're also
um
uh knowledgeable that if there is
a a noise issue this can be brought back
to the licensing authority to be
considered and licensed to be reviewed
under normal circumstances when they are
nice and noise issues
um
it comes under the Environmental Health
Department to investigate whether or not
there is a a statutory nuisance caused
with licensing it's slightly different
if you are required to
maintain a fairly Noise free environment
and not cause a nuisance the nuisance
doesn't need to meet that statutory
provision so a license can be brought
back to the subcommittee and they can
decide whether to review A license
they can revoke it they can amend it in
any way they like that they can impose
conditions to to address that issue
so on that ground the the licensing
subcommittee has agreed to Grant the
license
with the amended hours
um just a reminder though that if there
are issues because the the top committee
the members were concerned because of
the impact it's very difficult to tell
with the building that they're not
familiar with and we don't know what the
noise attenuation will be like
um but they are comforted by the the
model of premises you want to operate
and that's been sufficient for them to
come to this decision
there is a right of appeal against this
decision and that appeal is open to
anyone who has made representations to
the the licensing Authority and the
appeal can be made in writing to the
magistrates court within 21 days of
receiving notification of the decision
I think that's it Chef there's anything
you want to try before you close the the
subcommittent
uh no thank you very much Mr Lou I think
you've summarized the deliberations and
and they were um considerable
deliberations as you know because we
were gone for some time so
um with with all of that done I will
bring this meeting to a close at this
point um I I'd just like to give a
personal thanks to everybody that has
attended thank you for your patience
this morning it's been a long long
meeting
um and thank you also for your conduct
as well it's always um quite a
challenging process when it's online
like this so thank you very much to
everybody for for the conducts Etc but
other than that I will uh close this
meeting for now and uh thank you all
very much for your time